Ron DeSantis would not be the governor
of Florida if not for Donald Trump and
so what I'm seeing here is a level of
disloyalty I think he's going to pay for
ultimately and that's just not how you
treat someone that got you this far he's
44 years old he's the governor of the
Free State of Florida and by the way
from what I could tell he's done a
pretty good job at it yeah just be loyal
to the person that got you here in the
first place and then you could be The
Heir Apparent for the future but my fear
is that he is being talked into doing
this by a lot of other people that are
going to make a lot of money and
basically what we saw yesterday we were
kind of talking about it before the show
how he looks like a hostage patient
right now he looks like he's being held
hostage to do this and I think there are
a lot of people in Florida that simply
want him to stay in Florida and be the
governor and do the job that they
elected him to do